all right I am Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle from Washington tonight and
we begin the hour with a scandal of
monumental significance
finally with Republicans in charge of
the house the rocks are being lifted on
the coveted cover-up and the right that
we see underneath is what we warned you
about long ago
rank corruption at the heart of our
federal response
now the former CDC director under Trump
Dr Robert Redfield was questioned about
Anthony fauci's mad scramble to conceal
the role he and others played with green
lighting the funding to the Wuhan lab in
China
so what did Redfield think of the paper
that fauci pressured scientists to write
back in February 2020 that would
conclude ultimately that covid most
likely did not escape from a lab this
whole approach that was taken under its
antithetical to science thank you
science has debate and they squashed any
debate do you
use the paper does hide the truth I
think it's an inaccurate paper that
basically was part of a narrative that
they were creating remember this
pandemic did not start in January at the
seafood market we now know there was
infections all the way back into
September this was a narrative that was
decided that they were going to say this
came from the wet market and they were
going to do everything they could to
support it to negate any discussion
about the possibility that this came
from a library
but wait a second wait a second Anthony
fauci insisted under oath that the gain
of function research the riskiest
research you can do on a virus wasn't
being done at the Wuhan lab with our
help
Dr fauci was a firmatively towed and
told in an email that ni Aid had a
monetary relationship with the Wuhan
Institute through Eco Health Alliance he
he was told this in January 27th of
2020. do you think that Dr fauci
intentionally lied under oath to senator
Paul when he vehemently denied nih's
funding of gain of function research I
think there's no doubt that NIH was
funding gain or function research is it
likely that American tax dollars funded
the gain of function research that
created this virus I think it did not
only from NIH but from the state
department usaid and from DOD
okay do you realize what this all means
well
not surprisingly Redfield told the
committee that he found himself shut out
of key calls early on in the pandemic
and that was when fauci and Company
realized that Redfield was not going to
tow the party line
why do you think you were excluded from
those calls because it was I was told to
me that they wanted a single narrative
and that I obviously had a different
point of view
all about the science well these
sanctimonious camera hounds who flank
Trump day after day in the White House
briefing room these people who were
pushed pushing for these damaging
lockdowns and smearing good doctors and
researchers who knew the truth about
inexpensive antiviral treatments
they did more than grandstand on camera
though these people those people
destroyed public trust in our Public
Health officials and our entire Public
Health System
so why weren't fauci his boss Francis
Collins and their useful idiot Deborah
Burks at all interested in discussing
what renowned experts were saying about
when and how covet spread
what explains their stunning lack of
curiosity
in September of 2019 three things
happened in that lab
one is they deleted the sequences
it was highly irregular second thing
they did was they changed the command
and control of the lab from the civilian
control to the military control
highly unusual and the third things they
did which I think is really telling is
they let a contractor redo the
ventilation system in that Laboratory
there must be accountability here there
must be full transparency on the money
we funneled to Wuhan yeah all courtesy
of you the U.S taxpayers
if our own Public Health officials had a
direct or indirect involvement in the
research that led to This Global
pandemic
Merrick Garland our attorney general the
entire doj should be ready to impanel a
grand jury there should be indictments
oh no but remember he thinks the biggest
threat facing the American people are
guys like that so-called Q Anon Shaman
they threw in jail he's the big threat
the big money in medical research from
Pharma and from the federal government
it has corrupted huge swaths of our
scientific community and it must stop
the the Santa Fe Community is
is very afraid to speak up on political
issues and I think the reason is that um
the government grounds are handed out
through this system of peer peer review
commissions and so you don't want you
don't want any single scientist on your
peer review committee to vote against
you this means that
they cannot be relied upon in the way
that I think we would like them to to be
independent and forthright and call it
as they see it
for revealing how the sausage is made by
the way that was the former medical
editor of the New York Times
for how the whole scientific hierarchy
cares more about their grants than the
health of the American people Nicholas
Wade you just saw there was attacked by
committee Democrats
inviting someone with discredited and
dangerous views like Mr ways to testify
on the origins of this pandemic which
has disproportionately harmed
communities of color
is not responsible credible oversight
for race of people who have suffered
endured and survived three centuries of
slavery oppression deprivation
degradation I'm absolutely offended that
you would have the opportunity to take
this platform and to add anything of
significance to it
Mr Wade left out enough
figures out smearing him of course this
is just a textbook as we we've talked
about so much on the Ingram angle
more than just the relationship with
China that fauci Etc were protecting as
we found out back in February 2020 what
was utmost was of utmost importance to
fauci watch
I think early on in the outbreak it was
clear that there was some muddling of
information but over the last several
weeks the Chinese authorities have
really been very explicit that they were
going to not tolerate any misinformation
going out I'm surprised that you would
say that given what we know about
China's pattern of lie
critical issues Dr fauci
Chinese scientists we've dealt with I've
dealt with myself personally for years
if not decades I have faith that they
are not distorting things
so China will not let any misinformation
go out he's reassuring the American
public on China's behalf in that
interview I did with him in February
2020.
the money the power the fame the media's
complicity with all of this
in the dangerous and lucrative Obsession
that so many had in the medical
community with this gain of function
research that was all more important to
all of these people including fauci than
coming clean about important facts at
every stage of a global pandemic hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else